it's absolutely brilliant news for his
family brilliant news for Shaka and
brilliant news for all the campaigners
for shockers released and for those MPs
has spoken out in Parliament and joined
with us to publicize Jacques ordeal and
why ask now now that he is on his way
home that he is given the freedoms that
he's been denied for so long and we we
do demand that the freedoms he is given
he's not restricted in any way because
he has been held in a terrible situation
for nearly 14 years denied family life
denied the the freedoms that we have in
this country and now he is about to be
returned and we hope that will be a safe
return and we were watching to see that
he is he's given the safety and respect
that he deserves and we did call on the
government to make sure that this does
not happen again his harsh treatments
and abuse should shame all of those who
could have brought it to an end so much
sooner
he was never held for anything that he
did he was held for information which he
did not have and he was tortured even so
even though he had nothing to say
nothing to tell them because he was only
in Afghanistan to do good to do good and
do charitable work he had a dream to do
good to other people and his dream was
shattered for nearly 14 years and we
call on the government to have a a judge
led inquiry to see why he was held for
so long and if the government or anyone
else was complicit in keeping him away
from his family for so long why are you
concerned that the government would
place restrictions on him when he
returns well we have heard that there
will be robust security arrangements and
we hope that those robust security
arrangements in the UK UK are to protect
his freedom because he needs to be
respected and to be given an opportunity
to recover because he has very severe
health conditions that need medical
attention so we do hope that he is
allowed to have the peace and the
freedom that he's so much designed and
for his family who have suffered so much
and it's brilliant news for all of the
people who have stood for so long and
who have suffered so long who have
leafleting who have been out on the
streets telling the people that this is
a terrible injustice and we can now rest
assured that we will be there watching
and making sure that he has the
opportunity to be free now and let's
broken this news today it is brilliant
news for everybody who believes that
freedom is something that we all should
cherish and deserve joy have you spoken
to his family at all his family have had
many opportunities to speak to the media
but we do know you've spoken to
themselves his father-in-law and his
father nor said to me he would only
believe that Chaka is returned when he
sees him with his own eyes and I know
that the family are waiting and have
been waiting for nearly 14 years to see
their loved one again and I know that
the family will be delighted to be able
to talk to him freely I haven't spoken
to the family myself but I'm sure there
will be an opportunity in the near
future is there an issue now of
compensation given that he did face 14
years in a prison without any charges
and if there is an issue of compensation
where should it come from
I believe all of the issues regarding
checker will be dealt with by his
lawyers in good time
right now we need to celebrate the fact
that he he has been released and not
before time he could have been released
many many years ago eight years ago he
was cleared for release he faced no
charges he faced no trial and it is now
an opportunity for us to rejoice in the
fact that he is now free and let's hope
that when he he
is not able to see the Sun again he
would he was so you were so fearful that
he would die in Grant Avenue and that he
would be denied the opportunity to see
the Sun this is a man who's been denied
every freedom everything and by being
present in Guantanamo and he was
tortured every day brutally tortured but
the mental torture have not been with
his family has been the worst and yet
his strength and fortitude has kept him
going all these years and I know that
strength will be with him when he plans
how he will use his reason to benefit
society George do you know anything
about the logistics for when he lands
here in the UK will he be debriefed by
the security services will you be
reunited with his family immediately do
you have any details as yet we have been
told that he would like to see his wife
and talk to her about the children and I
heard that that wish that thing simple
wish is granted
and I believe that his lawyers are
trying to enable that to happen and then
we understand he will need hospital
treatment for his many ailments